Stephen Strange
the illuminati will see you now we will see what
kind of dr strange you are
Welcome back everyone
this will be my full doctor strange 2 multiverse
of madness review video hopefully you've had a
chance to see the movie by now it's been out for
a couple days if you're new to the channel i will
do specific videos for the post-credits scene
full breakdown easter eggs for the entire movie
especially talking about all the things that it
sets up because there are a couple very specific
in the moments that really want to beat you in
the face with like the really big avengers level
big crossover event that they're teasing up so
be sure to subscribe to get all those videos
and really big spoiler warning for the movie if
you have not seen it yet because we'll be talking
about specific things during this video getting
to the incursion of it all probably the best
thing that they could have said during this movie
everybody just hoping that they're building up
to that secret wars event then they say incursion
like 20 different times during the movie which is
marvel understanding their assignment for like the
next big infinity saga level crossover event but
seriously though when this movie actually comes
out on home video the new drinking game is going
to be drink every time someone says incursion
during the movie and i know there's going to
be a ton of questions about this i'll probably
even need to do a separate video about it but
when they talk about incursions they're talking
about alternate universes going to war with each
other which is a secret wars situation battle
world situation which is completely different
from the kang multiverse war which is about
different timelines going to war with each other
there'll probably be a lot of confusion about this
in the next couple years i think that they'll deal
mostly with the kang multiverse war like these
alternate timelines going at war with each other
during ant-man 3 quantum mania enduring
loki season 2 but the stuff in doctor
strange they're teasing with all the incursions
going to war with each other different universes
is going to be the big avengers level secret wars
crossover so just to be clear kang multiverse war
and secret wars incursions two completely separate
concepts i think most people will come out of this
movie just freaking out about all the crossovers
and what it means for the future of multiverse
cameos and the big crossover event that they're
teasing in the post credit scenes but overall
i felt like it was a pretty decent movie they did
like i said understand the assignment even though
we all thought that it was going to be crazy big
it did not wind up being infinity war 2.0 avengers
end game 2.0 that's why i think the run time is
so short really this movie when you think about
it is a pretty simple plot like it could just
be a couple extra episodes of wandavision like
wandavision episode 10 11 and 12 and boom you're
done it's just that a couple small parts of the
movie were dedicated to this really big thing like
oh and by the way we have this massive massive
thing that we're setting up in the future that all
you big comic book fans will know everything about
the minute we say the word and i think the first
time that they actually mentioned that is when
reed richards says incursion when he's talking
to the illuminati i believe that he was the
first person in the movie that mentions the word
incursion and that's really just what you want
to hear when you're thinking about secret wars
time runs out incursions universes colliding with
each other universe is being destroyed everyone
just bring on all those crazy multiverse cameos
now it really does feel like avengers 5 is gonna
be full-blown secret wars or they'll just call
it secret wars and not call it an avengers movie
but that's basically what it'll be how do you go
bigger than avengers end game the near destruction
of an entire universe where you tease the near
destruction of the entire multiverse with many
alternate universes can i transport to this planet
the fantastic four affirmative and there's another
who was a big help to me against carnage and venom
my friend iron man benedict cumberbatch elizabeth
olsen were at the top of their game i feel like
elizabeth olsen really brought in this movie
she definitely understood the assignment
they really gave her character a huge upgrade
during wandavision like they just gave her the
time to flesh out that character and a lot of what
you see in this movie is just a continuation of
what you felt towards the end of wandavision but
i think what this movie delivers that wandavision
didn't is that it really takes scarlet witch to
that villain territory she's more of an anti-hero
like she plays a bit of a villain during the movie
like everybody in the comics whose big scarlet
witch fan was waiting for her to do but the whole
idea is that they wanted you to understand where
she was coming from and that was what wandavision
was meant to do create that bond between her and
her children while she also literally created her
children which they call out several times in this
episode like you created your children out of pure
magic it was funny to hear the way they wrote her
clap back to that line creating her children out
of magic when she said don't all mothers do that
that was kind of her go-to ammunition for people
who are questioning what she was doing during
the course of the film like different characters
tell her to stop look at what you're doing you're
hurting all these people but they want to show you
how dedicated she is to the idea of her children
she's just willing to go that far but it winds
up corrupting her like we see mcu doctor strange
kind of be corrupted during the course of the
movie cannot wait to see that spin out of control
in the future crossovers in this big secret
wars incursion event that they're building up to
you just love to see things go wrong in exactly
the right way one of the big surprises though was
how small a part of the movie america chavez was
most of you know at least a little bit about her
from the comics i was expecting her to be a much
bigger part of the plot even though she was sort
of the leading mcguffin of the film there were
several mcguffins but she was like the biggest
mcguffin because the whole idea is that scarlet
witch wanted her power to go across the multiverse
but in reality they really just kind of give you
a taste of her character with the idea that she'll
be a much bigger character in future productions
but it's sort of like watching elizabeth olsen
back during avengers age of ultron like she was
an important character but a relatively small part
of the film then when she got to future movies
they gave her much bigger character development
there are a lot of vision references even though
vision himself wasn't actually featured during the
film which was another big surprise he's a part of
the film like he's a big part of the story but he
himself wasn't physically on screen it'll be the
same situation with america chavez when they build
up to more young avengers type of crossovers with
these younger characters they keep introducing
getting to the cameos of it all because there's
so many things we have to say about the cameos
themselves just so many big things they
were doing even though the actual duration
of their cameos was relatively short the way they
explained them in the movie is that they exist in
universe 838 which isn't from the comics 838 isn't
meant to be a reference to any specific illuminati
introduction in the comics on their earth they had
another avengers infinity war event but instead of
the avengers the illuminati wind up forming and
the way they explained it is that the illuminati
formed as a think tank to stop what was going
on with thanos and stop what was going on with
their version of doctor strange even though their
scene was really brief a lot of people will be
complaining how come they weren't a bigger part of
the film i think the implication is that we'll see
versions of those characters come back really soon
like they're working on a fantastic four movie
right now and for example even though they kill
off most of the illuminati which did kind of suck
the reason why they're variants is because you
can kill as many variants as you want and you
still have other versions that the actors
can come back and play from other universes
so like john krasinski can come back as a version
of reed richards from another universe same thing
with patrick stewart professor x all the other
characters you could kill like a hundred of them
and there'd still be versions out there that
could come back i think for the most part all
our predictions on who was on the team was about
95 correct it was really just like the last one
we were all kind of wondering about because
the way they were shaded in the background
it was patrick stewart's professor x from
a universe that was very similar if not the
x-men the animated series universe like that was
an animated series and they did have an animated
universe during the big transition when they were
going between different universes they even played
the theme song from x-men the animated series when
they introduced his character so i think they just
really wanted you to be thinking about the actual
animated series itself because they're all meant
to be from this one singular universe that means
that in this universe there is already a version
of the x-men with all those mainstream characters
like wolverine cyclops jean grey baron mordo of
their universe had become sorcerer supreme he
was a member of their team john krasinski like
i said reed richards of the fantastic four
in this universe there is a version of the
baxter foundation he is a version of sue richards
there his children franklin richards valeria their
version of captain marvel was maria rambo she was
just the person who was the test pilot on the day
that they were testing that faster than light
drive got in the accident and got the tesseract
powers hayley atwell is a version of captain
carter from this universe like i said she is
the first avenger of this particular universe and
i think probably the biggest surprise was ants and
mounts version of black bolt in a much more comic
book accurate looking costume that was really the
one that we were all kind of wondering about like
who is this is it a black panther variant is it
going to be anson mounts black bolt character
from the tv show this officially canonizes the
inhumans to the mcu i was a little surprised that
they included the ultron variants of iron man's
iron legion without actually mentioning iron man
but i think the idea is that he's either not part
of the team or didn't choose to be part of the
team or he's dead in this universe and that's
why you didn't see actual iron man on the team so
he's kind of part of the story through the ultron
substory line here with the robots they use but
he's not actually on screen the whole thing with
john krasinski playing a version of mr fantastic
though i think we were all fan casting him several
years ago like it would be amazing if he was
gonna do this but when people do that typically
it doesn't wind up working out in reality so this
quick cameo was a way to sort of have their cake
and eat it too like here's your fan service but
theoretically if they want to have a different
version of reed richards show up in the future
they could cast a different actor and just say
oh it's a variant from a different universe and
because starting with his character he's the
person that teases all these incursions the big
time runs out storyline during the comics where
the illuminati have to deal with their own version
of incursions before secret wars happens i think
they're trying to set up the idea of doing way
more multiverse versions of characters way more
variants so that theoretically when we get to our
mcu version of a fantastic four reboot movie that
movie will be an alternate universe version of
the team but it will be connected to the mcu now
also john watson directed spiderman no way home
directed all the mcu spider-man films just dropped
out of directing the fantastic four mcu movie a
lot of people think that he did that so that he
can wind up directing spider-man 4 in a couple
years but now that they need another director
for the fantastic four movie john krasinski
would actually be a really badass director if
he could do both directing and playing the lead
actor because they keep teasing this concept
of incursions and universes colliding with each
other people traveling across different universes
i also think that this time runs out scenario the
secret war scenario is one of the ways that they
introduce a lot of x-men into the mcu like
oh they'll just say that they're all coming
from alternate universes and they'll have them
look like whatever they want them to look like
the second post-credits scene with bruce campbell
even felt kind of like a deadpool moment with
him breaking the fourth wall that only deadpool
typically does although scarlet witch kinda broke
the fourth wall earlier in the film just a little
bit the fourth wall break that bruce campbell did
was more of a deadpool style fourth wall break
like he was joking at the audience in meta joking
about the film itself while talking about the
plot he looks at the camera and laughs in relief
saying that it's over thank god it's over i'm not
punching myself anymore but also it was meant to
be a meta joke about the movie being over like he
was laughing at us the audience saying thank god
that the movie is over which is something you
would expect to see deadpool do making fun of
yourself making fun of your own movie while you're
a character in that movie overall i think they did
a pretty decent job setting doctor strange up in
the next leg of his journey like the whole idea
i think is that they're taking doctor strange
to the place where his humanity is questioned
like the same thing that is happening to him
happened to sinister strange and he's gonna have
to ask the same questions to himself because
of that third eye he's starting to lose his
humanity he's getting more and more powerful he's
corrupted by the darkhold he'll have to question
his humanity when he appears in future movies
in whatever doctor strange three winds up being
and it sounds like clea is gonna be a big part
of that i have a whole bunch of breakdown videos
my post credit scene video will probably
be the next video to post where i'll talk
more specifically about secret wars teasers the
incursions time runs out all the really cool stuff
and then doing clea from the comics some of you
also been asking me about doing merch for my
channel or how to support the channel now youtube
is actually letting you support me by leaving tips
on my videos using that special heart underneath
each of the actual videos is right here they're
supposed to give you guys some special power-ups
whenever you do that for each of my videos so when
you try that out let me know if it's working for
you so if you want to support the channel that's
the best way to do it right now thank you to
all of you for all of your support if you have
any questions about what was going on with the
plot the characters or the post-credits scenes
just write them in the comments below and i'll add
them to my bonus videos in the next couple of days
wait you wait for everything you can click here
for that post-credit scene video i'll update the
link as soon as i post that and you can click
here for my moon knight episode 6 finale video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!